[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نصها هيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
امريكا في مواجهه كرويه مع ايران وسياسيه
ضد النظام طهران في موقف دفاعيا داخل
الملعب وهجومي ضد المحتاجين
روسيا تتوعد باستهداف البادجيات والمانيا
المتردده لا تستبعد تزويد اوكرانيا
بالمنظومه الصاروخيه
الله يبارك فيك فوق
كاميرا العربيه ترصد في صور حصريه ضبط
الجيش الليبي لقارب مهاجرين غير الشرعيه
قرب طوبرق
نمو الشحنه العالمي في خطر وسط توقعات
الاقتصاديه سلبيه وخشيه من سيناريو 2021
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه حراكم شعبي لا
مطلب له سوى الحريه والحياه حق لا طالما
كتما نظام الايراني اصوات طالبيه لكن هذه
المره يبدو ان اصوات المحتاجين في المدن
الايرانيه كافه زعزعت كرسيه ونظامه القمعي
وجعلته للمره الاولى يقروا بما فعلت ايديه
وعلى لسان القائد في الحرس الثوري امير
علي حاج زاده قائلا ان اكثر من 300 شخص
سقطوا في البلاد بينهم اطفال منذ
الاحتجاجات الحصيله التي اعترف بها النظام
الايراني تعد الاقرب الى عدد 416 شخصا
الذين اكدت منظمه حقوق الانسان في ايران
لهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خبايا يا حملات القمع التي مارسها النظام
الايراني لعقود ظهرت الى العلن بعد القمع
الذي مارسه النظام ضد الاحتجاجات يبدو ان
نتحركا اتن ضد طهران من اروقه الامم
المتحده هذه المره فاقد افاد ديكلوماسيون
مطلعون ان المجلس الاقتصادي والاجتماعيه
التابع للامم المتحده
سيصوت في الرابع عشر من ديسمبر على مشروع
قرار امريكي باستبعاد ايران من هيئه الامم
المتحده للمراه فيما اوضح الدبلوماسيه في
الامم المتحده ان الولايات المتحده ودولا
اخرى تجري اتصالات المكثفه لحد الدعم
لاخراج ايران من هيئه المراه
هذا ونشره قناته ايران انترناشونال
تسريبات صوتيا لاحده قاده قوات المسج
يظهروا هلا عن نظام الايراني من
الاحتجاجات التي عمت المدن الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
والصلاه على الصلاه
البلجيكيه اوليفيا فاندوكاستال العام في
المجال الانسانيه والموقوف دون سبب في
ايران منذ تسعه اشهر عبرت عن قلقها من
تراجعه حالته الصحيه مشيره الى انه بدا
اضرابا عن الطعام للاحتجاج على معاملته
بطريقه غير انسانيه على احد وصفها ونددت
عائلتهستال بما وصفته بالظلم الوحشي ناقله
فحوى اتصال ان يقال ان المواطن البلجيكي
اجره اخيرا معها قنصليه
معنى من لندن البحث في الشعر الايرانيه
عارف نصر استاذ عارف ابدا معك من اخر خبر
او انها عن المعتقل البلجيكي في ايران
اوليليه دوندوكاستال كيف برايك يوظف
النظام الايراني مساله المعتقلين الغربيين
لديه
تحيه طيبه لك والمشاهده العربيه الكرام
نحن نعلم بان بادبيات النظام الايراني
هنالك مصطلح يطلق عليه دبلوماسيه الرهائن
وربما هذه الدبلوماسيه بدات مع بدايه
النظام الايراني وموضوع الرهائن
الامريكيين وبالتالي هو استطاع من خلال
هذه الدبلوماسيان يحصل على اموال طائله
وكذلك ان همم ربما يصل الى بعض النقاط
التي يريدها حتى بالملف النووي الاخير نحن
ايضا شهدنا كثير من التنازلات الامريكيه
همم بواسطه الرهائن سواء الملتويجيه جنسيه
او الرهاين الذين هم بالاساس الاوروبيين
ويؤتونها الى ايران لاغراض سياحيه وعلميه
بل حتى في بعض الحالات تكون هنالك دعوات
رسميه من جامعات او من مراكز بحثيه الى
بعض الباحثين ثم يتم همم اعتقالهم داخل
البلاد ضمن هذه الاستراتيجيه التي همم
يعرفوها بيجيب له ناسيه الرهائن
ااا مساله اخرى تحدثنا عنها بالامس ولكن
تبدو لافته ايضا اليوم الاعتراف من قبل
النظام بسقوط 300 قتيل يعني هو صحيح ليس
اا الرقم الحقيقي هو يعني المنظمات
الحقوقيه تتحدث عن اكثر من ذلك ولكن اقرار
النظام الايراني بسقوط هذا العدد من
القتلى في الاحتجاجات ماذا يعني
انا اعتقد بان هذا الامر همم
له عده ابعاد مهمه يجب قراءتها اهمها انا
اعتقد بان هذه النقطه ايضا يعني هذه
النقطه التي يجب التركيز عليها وهي انها
تاتي من قبل
الجنرال الحجي زاد الذي اسقط الطائره
الاوكرانيه وسياخ حتى كان حول هذا الامر
لذلك هو حاول ان ان ربما يغلل من اهميه
قضيه الطائره الاوكرانيه
ويبغي باللوم على جهات اخرى هي المسؤوله
داخل الحرس الثوري لغايه الاكثر من 300
شخص لذلك ممكن قراءه هذا الامر بجانب من
جوانب على انه ايضا محاوله لالغاء التهم
بين الحرس الثوري وبين جهاته المختلفه
لكما اضافه الى هذا الموضوع هنالك همم
مواضيع همم المواضيع الحقوقيه وكذلك
محاوله الى الى
هذا الموضوع من خلال ايجاد لجنه التخصص
حقائق داخليه فما ستعترف ببعضها هذه
القتله نعم
قبل ان اتركك فقط اريد ان اسال على مساله
اخرى همم تبدو لها ارتباطات بمما يحدث في
الداخل مساله توظيف النظام الايراني
لمشاركته في كاس العالم كذلك وتخوفه ربما
من ان يدلي اللاعبون الايرانيون باي تصريح
المباراه الان همم النتيجه هدف لصفر لصالح
امريكا مقابل ايران وكنت قرات خبرا كذلك
على افراج همم القوات الايرانيه السلطات
الايرانيه عن 1200 سجين بعد فوز المنتخب
الايراني على منتخب ويلز في كاس العالم في
قطر كذلك برايك كيف يحاول النظام الايراني
الاستفاده من كاس العالم همم مع
الاحتجاجات الداخليه
الواقع بان التسريبات الصوتيه كشفت جميع
لاعبي النظام الايراني بهذا الخصوص كشفت
بان هنالك استخدام اكثر من 2000 موظف
معظمهم امنيين الى كاس العالم في قطر
وجاء هذا الامر مباشره على يد او على لسان
همم اللواء همم
قريش مساعد قوات البسيج بالتسريبات التي
حصلت خلال الايام وفيما يبدو بان النظام
الايراني يحاول من خلال الحضور الكثيف
بهذه القضيه همم
قطر او في الدوحه بان يؤكد ان ربما الذين
يعرضون نظامهم غله بينما نحن نعلم بان همم
داخليا حتى الان معظم الشعب الايراني
يناصر الفريق الامريكي لصالح او ربما اكثر
من الفريق الوطني الايراني لانه يعتبرونا
همم فريق جمهوريه اسلاميه وليست فريق وطني
نعم و التذكير فقط سلطات القضائيه كذلك
اعلنت الافراج بكفاله على حارس المرمى
الايراني في المنتخب الوطني همم السابق
بارفيز بورماند بامر من المدعي العام وكان
هو اعتقل كذلك على خلفيه الاحتجاجات في
ايران شكرا جزيلا لك عارف ناصر الباحث في
شان الايراني كنت معنا من لندن
[موسيقى]
اذا تطرقنا للمباراه التي تجمع الان
امريكا وايران في هذه الاثناء فهي الساخنه
سياسيا وحتى ان المصافحه التقليديه بين
اللاعبين باتت حدثا يهتم العالم بمتابعته
في كاس العالم عام 1990 التقطت الولايات
المتحده وايران وقام انا ذاك اللاعبون
الايرانيون بنزع فتيل القلق الجي او سياسي
من خلال تسليم الورود البيضاء للاعبين
الامريكيين قبل المباراه لكن المباراه
اليوم تاتي في ظروف مختلفه حيث الوضع
الداخلي في ايران مشحون بشكل كبير اذا
ترزح البلاد تحت عقوبه الامريكيه قاسيه
منذ عقود صحفته نيويورك الى ان اللعبه
اصبحت خطا امامنيا اخر في الصراع بين
الخصمين الجي او سياسيين اما صحيفه واشنطن
فنقلت عن الكسلاس المدافع في المنتخب
الامريكي قوله ان منتخبهم ناضج بما فيه
الكفايه وذو خبره الكافيه لمعرفه ان هذا
لا علاقه له بالحكومه
صحيفه وصف الجورنال كشفت ان كل نتيجه
مباراه تحمل شحنه اضافيه من التفسير
الاكبر حيث النتيجه هي اكبر من مجرد فوز
او تعادل او خساره بل انه يقع في منظور ما
يمثله لمستقبل الرياضه في الولايات
المتحده والطريقه التي ينظر بها العالم
الى الكره القدم الامريكيه
اما انطونيو بلانكين فعبر عن ثقته في فوز
المنتخب الامريكي امام نظيره الايراني في
اطار مباريات كاس العالم الرجل اكد على
عدم وجود اي جوانب جيوس سياسيه او خاصه في
هذا الشعب اتعاون نستمع لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي
عمرو
لكن البيت الابيض
واقفه خطوه تعكس حاله القلق من السلطات في
ايران من اي تصرف قد يحرجها على المستوى
العالمي كشف مصدر معني بامن المباريات في
كاس العالم بقطر لشبكه سي ان ان عناصر
التابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني موجودون في
قطر لمراقبه لاعبي منتخبهم وجمع معلومات
عنهم الى ان لقاء جمع المدرب البرتغالي
لمنتخب الايراني كروش مع ضباط الحرس
الثوري دون ذكر تفاصيله مضيفا ان عائلات
لاعبيه منتخب ايران تعرضت للتهديد بالسجن
والتعذيب اذا لم يحسن اللاعبون التصرف
عموما نتابع الاجواء من الدوحه مع مفرنا
الى هناك ليث بزاري
ليث اهلا بك همم معنى همم انقل لنا
الاجواء من عندك في هذه الاثناء مع
المباراه يعني التي تحمل اكثر من بعد
المباراه بين ايران وامريكا
نعم صهيب يعني هذه المباراه اخر مباراه
وديه كانت بين الولايات المتحده وايران
عام 2000 وكانت هذه المباراه الوحيده ولكن
اليوم نتحدث عن مباراه فوز لامريكا 10
تفضلت قبل قليل ولكن الذي رصدناه ولاحظناه
قبل قليل ان هذه الساعه خلفي كانت مليئه
بالمشجعين الايرانيين الخارج الملعب خارج
الملعب همم خارج ملعب الثمامه طبعا ولكن
بعد بعد فوز او تسجيل هذا الهدف الامريكي
الكثير انسحبوا لانه نشاهد الكثير من
الايرانيين الذين المشجعين المنتخب
الايراني هنا في هذه الساحه والهدوء كما
يعني عاده لما يكون هناك مباراه او بين
منتخبين خصوصا في كاس العالم يكون هناك
همم اغاني وموسيقى وحركه اكثر من ذلك ولكن
كمان تشاهد يعني الساحه خارج لا يوجد
الكثير من الناس حتى البوابات مدخل
الجمهور عاده تكون مفتوحه ولكنها اغلقت
اعتقد لان الكثير للتذكير فقط ليس انه
المباراه ما تزال مستمره يعني الشوط الاول
انتهى بنتيجه هدف مقابل صفر في انتظار
يعني النتيجه النهائيه
المباراه ولكن دائما نتحدث نعم نتحدث كذلك
ربما على هل تمكنت من مشاهده او رصد يعني
اي همم يعني تضامن او اي اا شعارات او
ربما خشيه من التعبير على اي تضامن مع
المتظاهرين همم في داخل ايران لدى ان كان
المشجعين ال- الايرانيين او حتى اللاعبين
نعم اكيد صهيب شاهدنا قبل قليل قبل ساعتين
من الان فتيات يحملن صور محسا امينه
وشهدنا اخريات يحملن يافطات كتب عليها
اعمار اطفال غير بالغين اذا صحت تعبير
كانوا مسجون في السجون الايرانيه ويطالبون
هيوما رايتس الحقوق الانسانيه وطبعا
الكثير طبعا استغلوا وجود الكثير من وسائل
الاعلام هنا للتعبير عن ذلك للتعبير عما
يحدث في ايران كما شاهدنا يعني الكثير من
الجمعيات الحقوقيه التي وجدنا هنا كانت
هنا في امام الملعب وهي من اليابان كان
هناك من امريكا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهذا الحان يعني الكثير طبعا
لاحظنا انه ال- ال- الذي يحدث في ايران
الكثير من الشباب جيل الشاب عندما يخرج من
ايران يحاول توصيل صوت ما يحدث هناك عن
طريق ان كانت فعاليات رياضيه ثقافيه فنيه
وغيرها نعم هذا عن المباراه الجاريه الان
وكذلك ااا مباراه ويلز وانجلترا همم لكن
سؤال الاخير لك ليث سيكون عن الموعد الذي
ننتظره جميعا مباراه الاخضر السعودي همم
غدا نعم كل تمنيات بالتوفيق همم يعني كيف
هي استعدادات فريق السعوديه
حتى هذه اللحظه الذي لا يصدها انه يوجد
الكثير من السعوديون الذين قدموا هنا يعني
اثناء المباشر يوجد شخص يشاهد امام خلف
الكاميرات اريد بس انا اسال اذا معنا وقت
بس صهيب متى وصلت هنا متى وصلت من بدايه
الشوط الاول الى هنا الى قطر
يعني شاهدنا كثير شباب سعودي وصلوا اليوم
شاهدت في منطقه سوق واقف الكثير من الشباب
السعودي الذي يرتدي الاخضر طبعا والالوان
اللون الاخضر اللون المنتخب السعودي
وشاهدنا الكثير منهم وصلوا اليوم من منطقه
الاحساء من القصيم من وين
من الرياض من كل مكان
المملكه
مع برشلونه
سعودي همم موجود على منطقه الكورنيش يوجد
كمان مناطق اخرى يوجد كمان الكثير يريد ان
يذهب الى من كان اقامه المنتخب
ورؤيه لاعبين ان شاء الله يوفقكم ان شاء
الله انهم بيتاهلوا ان شاء الله الوقت
انتهى ولكن ليث في عجاله ما توقعاتك
للسعوديه غدا
اتوقع بكره مع المكسيك تكون النتيجه همم
اثنين واحد اثنين واحد طيب
بالتوفيق ان شاء الله اذا سنتابع جميعا
غدا هل المباراه الحاسمه من الدوحه اذا
مفرد العربيه التي باريس شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى اليمن قال رئيس الوزراء اليمني معين
عبد الملك ان هجمات الحوثيين على موانئ
ومنشات النفط يمثل اعلان حرب مفتوحه من
الجماعه المسلحه ونقل بيان لرئاسه الوزراء
عن عبد الملك قوله ان اثار هذه الحرب لن
تتوقف على المؤسسات الاقتصاديه الوطنيه
وفي اخبار الساعه بعد قليل
تحسبا لتزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه بعيده المدى
روسيا تجهز ملاجئ القنابل
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد والى ملف الازمه
الاوكرانيه حيث توعدت روسيا باستهداف
منظومه
الى اوكرانيا في مقال المستشار الالماني
انه لا يستبعد تزويد اوكرانيا بالمنظومه
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي قال ان انيته
همم حذر من تزويد اوكرانيا بنظام الفقري
وقت الدفاع الصاروقي واا ثم حلف شمال
الاطلسي بالكيان الاجرام قال اذا المحال
الامين العام يحلف بان يقوم بانيته بتزويد
المتعبين الاوكرانيين بامره اضافه الى
عسكريين من النيترو سيصبحون على الفور
هدفا مشروعا لقواتنا المسلحه
اما وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه ديميتر
كوليبا فقال ان بلاده تحتاج الى انظمه
الدفاع جوي لحمايه بنيتها تحتيه كما اكد
كوليبا خلال لقائه مع الامين العام لحلفي
الناتو ينسى السلطان برج في رومانيا على
ضروره التوفير مولدات ومحولات لتوفير ظروف
المعيشيه اللائقه للاوكرانيا
تمكننا من استعاده طاقتنا وتوفير ظروف
المعيشيه اللائقه للناس اما بالنسبه
لانظمه الدفاع الجوي فستمكننا من حمايه
البنيه التحتيه من الضربات الصاروخيه
الروسيه
التي يجب الاستعداد لها
ومن العاصمه الرومانيه بوخارست دول الناتو
تتحد بوجه بوتين ولا في البحر الاسود كذلك
ساحه لحرب جديده مثل الخليجيه الامريكيه
انطوني بليكن اكد ان دول النيترو متحده في
مواجهه الحرب التي تشنها روسيا على
اوكرانيا مشينا الى ان واشنطن والدول
الغربيه فرضت عقوبات غير مسبوق على موسكو
وستواصل الضغط على الاقتصاد الروسي اما
فيما يخص البحر الاسود فالتهب لينكير
روسيا بتحويل البحر الاسود الى ساحه حرب
عندما يتعلق الامر بمنطقه البحر الاسود
فهذه منطقه ذات اهميه استراتيجيه حيويه
بالنسبه لنا ولحلف شمال الاطلسيه حولت
روسيا اجزاء من البحر الاسود الى منطقه
حرب لقد راينا صواريخ قادمه من السفن
الحربيه الى المدن والبلدات الاوكرانيه
وسنقوم بتعزيز وجود الناتو من البحر
الاسود الى بحر البطيخ
وما تحدث عنهم
من البحر الاسود الى بحر البلطيق يحمل
علامات كثيره
لروسيا يعتبر البحر الاسود بمثابه لها ومن
طاقه الامنيه بالدرجه الاولى وذلك لحمايه
قواعدها العسكريه الموجوده في شبه جزيره
القرم خاصه الاسطول البحريه
بالاضافه الى حمايه روابطها الاقتصاديه
والتجاريه في كذلك مع الاسواق الاوروبيه
اوروبا اكثر اعتمادا على غازلها اما
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده فيمثل البحر
الاسود اهميه استراتيجيه باعتباره واحده
من اهم مناطق توسع الناتو شرق اوروبا خاصه
في ظل وجود ثلاث دول من اصل سته اعضاء في
النيتو وهم تركيا وبلغاريا ورومانيا كما
ان بحر البلطيق ايضا لا يقل اهميه عن
البحر الاسود بشكل اهميه استراتيجيه
للنيترويا خصوصا انه قد يصبح دائره نفوذ
بحلف شمال الاطلسي بما ان كل الدول المطله
على هذا البحر في حال انضمت السويد وفر
لندن الى الحلف ستصبح اعضاء فيه باستثناء
روسيا وعندها ستصبح موسكو في موقف اضعف
بان فرص الحلف لحصر لقوات البحريه الروسيه
في قواعدها ستصبح افضل مما هي عليه اصلا
فقتصاديا ستكون السفن الروسيه التي تغادر
مرفانتش العسكريه قرب سامبل سبورج عبره
خليجي في لندن من الشمال وكذلك من الجنوب
بدول اعضاء في النيتو اما في حال اندلاع
حرب في سيكون من الصعب على البحريه
الروسيه اجراء عمليات فوق سطح البحر
وعندها ربما يتعين عليها ان تتبنى موقفا
دفاعيا بدلا من الموقف الهجوم
معنا من واشنطن مايك ميلوري النائب مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي
السابق سيد مايك اهلا بك معنا شكرا على
قبول لك دعوه اخبار الساعه لهذا المساء
بدايه ابدا معك من مثلا منظومه لماذا تقلق
هذه المنظومه روسيا ولماذا برايك تتوعد
روسيا بانها ستقصف هذه المنظومه اذا ما
سلمها حلف شمال الاطلس الى اوكرانيا
ان اكون معك
في الفتره الحاليه ان روسيا قد ادركت
بانها لن تكسب هذه المعركه وخاصه على
الارض في مواجهه اوكرانيا اوكرانيا ما من
شيء يوقفها اي شيء لذا فان الروس قد توجهه
الى استراتيجيه مفادوها استهداف في
ال ال البنى التحتيه والمدنيه والمدنيه
ولا اعتقد ان هذه الاستراتيجيه سوف تفرح
لكن الامر الذي يوقفوا
الدفاعيه وجويه تحصل عليها اخرى اوكرانيا
فان منظومه سوف تكون مكونه
من نشر هذه المنظومه الى اوكرانيا الامر
الذي سوف يهدد اهداف الروسيه ولكن هذا قد
يكون هو واقع الحال في القريب
نعمراء الخارجيه في حلف شمال الاطلسي
اليوم في غرزه العاصمه ال الرومانيه حديث
همم على الدعم والمساعدات لاوكرانيا مع اا
وصول فصل الشتاء ومع تضرر البنيه التحتيه
وخاصه الكهرباء بشكل كبير بسبب الضربات
الروسيه هل هذا حقا ما يركز عليه الحلف
الان بمعنى انه مساله حسم الحرب ربما
مؤجله ام لا يعني همم الامران مجتمعه
للامرين
لانه كل ما طال عمد هل كان هناك اعداد
كبيره من المدنيين الذين يعانون ومع ذلك
من الواضح بان
بان الهجمات التي جنتها روسيا على البنا
التحتيه في اوكرانيا بحيث تمنع المواطن
الاوكرانيين من الحصول على التدفئه في فصل
الشتاء وجزء مما يعني يمكن ان نفعله هو
نقدم هذه المولدات
وكما تعلمون ويعلموا مشاهدكم في ان هذه
المولدات قد تقوم بمد كهرباء الى مساحات
شاسعه في البلاد
سوف يكون هناك
من قبل الحكومات التي سوف تتبرع بهذه
المولدات فضله
التي سوف ترسل هذه المولدات
بحيث يحصلون على الاساسيات للنجاه في فصل
الشتاء مايك ميلوري نائب مساعد وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه السابق من واشنطن
العاصمه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
ذكرت صحيفه ذا تايمز البريطانيه ان المدن
الروسيه وخاصه المناطق الحدوديه شهده
انتشارا مكثفا
لافتات التي ترشد الناس لملاجئ احتماء من
القنابل وذلك في وقت تدرس فيه الولايات
المتحده تزويده اوكرانيا باسلحه بعيده
المداح
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى منطقه اخرى شمالي سوريا اجواء
مشحونه
الغربيه المتحدث باسم الرئاسه التركيه
ابراهيم كالين اكد ان العمليه العسكريه
البريه على سوريا قد تبدا في اي وقت مضيفا
الحوار بين انقر ودمشق على مستوى
المخابرات مستمر بالمقابل قال قائد قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي انه لا يزال
يخشى هجوما بريا تركيا على الرغم من
التاكيدات الامريكيه مطالبا برساله اقوى
من واشنطن للضغط على تركيا
[موسيقى]
صحيح لم تكن وجهتهم النهائيه لكن افتقادهم
القدر الى او اقتادهم القدر الى بر الامان
بدلا من الغرق في البحر الابيض المتوسط
وحدته عسكريه تابعه للواء طارق بن زياد
بالجيش الليبي تمكنت من ضبطه مركبه صيد
تقل مهاجرين غير شرعيين قباله سواحل منطقه
كمبوت شرقي تبرق وفي تصريحات خاصه للعربيه
قبل العقيد نور محمد ان المركب كان يقل
علامته 550 مهاجرا غير نظامي من عده
جنسيات وان وجهتها كانت السواحل الايطاليه
البشر كانوا قد جهزوا لهذه العمليه منذ
اكثر من شهر كامل في اشاره الى ان اغلب
المهاجرين اطفال نساء
طبعا ااا
ثلاث ايام دوريات عندنا معلومات عليها ااا
منطقه البردي اللي هو
شرق ليبيا ومنطقه غامبول
سوريا
وبنغلا مصريه فهمت مخازن
وهاجرين الى ايطاليا البحر ما يسمحش
للهجره خاصه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
ضد الرقابه على الانترنت
[موسيقى]
مرحبا
قبل قليل حول التلويح التركي بعمليه
عسكريه بريه في شمال سوريا حول الموضوع
معنا من القامش للقمان احمي المتحدث
الرسمي باسم الاداره الذاتيه شمال شرق
سوريا السيد لقمان اهلا بكم معنا شكرا على
قبولك دعوه لهذا المساء من العربيه كان
هناك حديث
روسي بانه سيكون هناك
ضغط كذلك على الاتراك لعدم شن هذه العمليه
ولكن الحكومه التركيه تتحدث على انه
العمليه البريه قد تبدا في ايه لحظه همم
هل همم المناطق الكرديه دعنا نقول هي
مستعده لهذه العمليه
طبعا تهديدات التركيه ليست جديده
وتركيا عبر هذه السنوات الازمه السوريه
اعتدت على عده مناطق واحتلت مناطق عديده
منها شمال السوري لذلك استعدادات قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه للدفاع عن المنطقه
باستمرار تكون موضع تجديد وتحديث ان كان
هناك اي هجوم بري تركي فهذه القوات ستدافع
عن السكان وعن المنطقه وعن السياده
السوريه
طيب هل هناك استعدادات عسكريه
طبعا هذه بعض الامور قد تكون عسكريه بحته
ولكن قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه اعلنت
منذ التحديثات الاخيره بانها على كامل
الاستعداد اي عدوان تركي سواء كان بري او
كان بالطرق الاخرى او رد عليها ضمن
الاراضي سوريا
لقمان على ان هناك ما يشبه الصفقه انه كل
هذا الضغط والتهديد بالعمليه البريه
التركيه في شمال سوريا همم يمكن ان يتوقف
اذا ما عاود النظام السوري استلام المناطق
الحدوديه بين سوريا
وتركيا ما رايكم في هذا
طبعا نحن ضمن الحدود السوريه ونحن مواطنون
سوريين وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه من
تسميتها يتبين ايضا انها قوات سوريا ولا
علاقه لتركيا بالشان الداخلي السوري الذي
تدخلت فيه منذ الازمه السوريه اذا اتينا
الى
ما يقوله او ما تقوله الامم المتحده او
المبادله الاساسيه للقانون الدولي فيجب ان
لا تتدخل الدول المجاوره بالمشاكل
لا تنقسم وهناك مساواه بين الدول بشان
السياده لذلك الاعتداءات التركيه بهذا
الخصوص هو تعدي على سياده همم دوله
همم الامر همم الاخر همم كل ما يحدث الان
هو او المحاولات تكون في سبيل خفض التصعيد
الذي رفعته تركيا
اا ارجع تركيا للقبول بتفهمات عام 2019
التي وقعتها مع امريكا وكذلك مع الاتحاد
الروسي لان الجانب الاداره ذاتيه قد نفذت
جميع البنود المتعلقه بها نزول ذلك الوقت
ولكن تركيا لم تنفذ البنود المتعلقه
وما يحدث الان اا ان الاداره ذاتيه تطلب
من الجهات الضامنه ان يلزموا تركيا في
تركيا
جزيلا لكم سيد لقمان احمد متحدث الرسمي
باسم الاداره الذاتيه شمال شرق سوريا
هو منذ عام منذ العام الماضي ايه تلقى او
تلقي الاضطرابات الاقتصاديه وتدعيه جائحه
كورونا تلقي بثقالها على الاقتصاد العالمي
لتاتي الحرب في اوكرانيا العام الحالي
لتزيد الطين بالله اذا توقع مؤتمر الامم
المتحده للتجاره والتنميه ان تفقد وتيره
نشاط النقل البحري العالمي زخمها العام
المقبل وتشيله تقيمات اكبر لاكبر البنوك
الاستثماريه في العالم الى ان نمو
الاقتصاديه العالميه سيشهدوا مزيدا من
التباطؤ في عام 2023 ومن المتوقع ان يؤثر
التباطؤ على الملاحه البحريه التي تنقل
اكثر من 80% من التجاره المتداوله عالميه
الا ان رسوم الشحن بالنقلات قد تظل مرتفعه
تقرير المؤتمر توقع تراجع النمو في
التجاره البحريه العالميه الى واحد فصل 4%
هذا العام وان يظل عند نفس المستوى في
2023 ما يشير الى احتماليه العوده عام
2021 حيث دفعت زياده الانفاق الاستهلاكي
اسواق الشحن بالحاويات الى مستويات
القياسيه وادت الى التكدس في المانع في
انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]
صراع جديد بين الى الماسك والمعلمين على
تويتر يهدد بزوال المنصه عن متاجر
التطبيقات للهواتف الذكيه سببه تغييرات
المحتوى التي يفرضها الملك الجديد لتويتر
معتبرا انها تقدم مساحه او ساعه لحريه
التعبير بينما ينظر اليها المعلمون بانها
باب يفتح على خطاب الكراهيه والمعلومات
المختلطه
[موسيقى]
ونختم على هذا الخبر طريف من مونديال قطر
حيث تمكن احد المؤثرين على تطبيق تيك توك
من خداع المسؤولين والسلطات المختصه بعد
ان استطاع الولوج الى استاد مباراه
البرازيل وسويسرا وظن الجميع ان البرازيلي
ايجون اوليفيرا هو نجم فريق سامبا نيمار
نظرا للتشابه الكبير الذي يجمعهما في
المظهر وفي البنيه ومن مساعده اوليفيرا في
خداع الجماهير ورجال الامن انا نيمار كان
قد اصيب في مباراه سابقه وخرج متالما في
الشوط الثاني وسبق اوليفيرا ان خدع قناه
فورت نيوز امريكيه حيث نشرت مقطع فيديو
قيل انه يعود للنجم نيمار لكن عاده القناه
الامريكيه في وقت سابق وقالت انها خدعت
شهد
لا انا استعدي دوت كم مره
[موسيقى]
قبل الختام نترككم مشاهدينا مع هذه
المشاهد لاكبر بركان نشط في العالم حاليا
واسمه بركان الذي يقع في جزيره هاواي
الامريكيه
واترككم هذه الصور والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]